Another thing that Dr. Bright is not allowed
to do at the Foundation: No using excessive
force of any kind!
The SCP Foundation isn't exactly known for
using restraint when dealing with threats,
from blowing up small towns to immersing monsters
in baths of acid.
But thanks to the intervention of the Ethics
Committee over the years, the Foundation has
learned to handle things a bit more delicately,
when possible at least.
So no one is permitted to use excessive force
unless absolutely necessary.
And you know who it is never necessary for?
Dr. Bright.
And no, Dr., Excessive Force is not the same
thing as The Force, and you know it.
Stop calling yourself an Excessive Jedi.
Not a thing.